so I've been with my girl for seven
years he just got married we're not in
an open relationship but
from a porn perspective we shoot with
other girls stuff like that right yeah
but no other guys busting her coochian
ass out well you guessed it over the
weekend oh no something like that
happened she filmed her first ever scene
with another man I know he was mad
I'm angry I I agreed to it so I was like
I say angry might not be the word but
she was kind of like disappointed a
little bit like you five like color I
cut that's your sick you know I agree
she gave me a lot of outs on the way in
like she kind of kept telling me like if
you don't want me to I won't do it
fair enough but I I told her I'm like I
think you should do it let's let's get
it out the way
I was kind of surprised because I feel
like I can like intellectualize it and
from my perspective I don't think it
should be a big deal then after she
actually did it I'm not gonna lie I did
feel kinda